[Music]
foreign
the Press preview a first look at what
is on the front pages time to see what's
making the headlines with the daily
mirrors associate editor Kevin McGuire
and the Daily Mail columnist Sarah Vine
welcome to both of you so for a look at
the papers as usual let's start shall we
with
the Metro it suggests rail strikes could
continue for an extended period with the
rmt leader Mick Lynch refusing to
entertain the idea of driver only trains
Samuel Johnson that's the front of
Kevin's paper the mirror which carries
claims that Downing Street staff
destroyed evidence ahead of a Commons
investigation into partygate
the times has news of a plan to let
people keep their benefits and go back
to work to try to boost the economy
the financial times has word of cyber
attacks on its competitor the guardian
as well as Royal Mail amid concerns it
could be part of a wider wave of digital
crime the guardian leaves that story of
off of its own off the front page
instead reporting that there are calls
to ban the fossible installation of
energy prepayment meters in the homes of
people who fail to keep up with their
bills
and the star says it is Banning further
mention of Prince Harry from the paper
though even they aren't sure if they'll
stick to it so they say well a reminder
by scanning the QR code you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us so let's
head straight back to Kevin and Sarah
and Kevin let's kick off with the
guardian shall we use a further strikes
this time civil servants massive numbers
100 000 of them
yeah and 130 uh sorry 124 government
departments so there's another 33 000
also being balloted in including those
at hmrc revenue and Customs attacks so
that could be a real problem but it
shows that the the wave of disputes is
growing not uh not getting smaller and
it's because so many people at work have
problems with the cost of living they're
seeing their living standards fall at a
record rate the government is holding
out instead of offering what becomes a
fair and decent payer risers uh so so it
will get worse teachers uh have been
balloted too in England they could join
this wave so it's a big headache for the
government it's a big headache for the
public too but you know when everybody's
suffering I think the old traditional
Tory tactic was to demonize the trade
unions and the public would turn against
them so it's not happening because so
many people can see that their own
living standards are falling and there's
some respect for people who are having a
go trying to protect the living
standards well the Metro uh kicks off on
on the rail strikes as well that is
disruptive to people trying to get to
work as many do
um and giving evidence along with other
union leaders before MPS today and he's
specifically a cross about this idea to
have driver only trains which he says
the government shoehorned into any
agreement that was before them so you
know what do you think about driver only
trains Sarah and are they right not to
give an inch as the paper says
well I mean Mick Lynch is a very fright
person very very good at what he does
and he's I mean I think he's he's hit on
something because I think a lot of
people don't want driver only trains I
don't really want driver only trains I
was saying earlier I think we should
have nice conductors back and possibly
even a you know food Trolley going up
and down I think people don't like the
idea of of not having someone in
authority on their train it's sort of
you know it's it's it makes them nervous
and you know if something happens then
there's no one to help is there so I
think it's a quite a clever tactic of
mcniches because you know a lot of
people agree with him on this one I mean
at the beginning of the week we saw
um multiple meetings with multiple
ministers and secretaries of State in
different departments meeting union
leaders the following day you know they
talked about having these strike laws
um you know what does the government
need to do now Sarah do you think
um and and real deep discussions need to
um happen do they pat Cullen
um telling us this evening that we
really need to just start talking about
the pay that we we want
well I think I mean I think this whole
idea that this is some sort of organic
kind of uh rise in people striking is is
a bit disingenuous it's obviously a
massively well coordinated uh attack on
the government by the unions and they're
they're doing they're doing an excellent
job and and they're you know they are
making inroads in the sense that I think
people people are being beginning to get
worn down by it all and interestingly I
don't think people are losing sympathy
necessarily for the strikers I mean
certainly not for the I'm not sure about
the civil servants people tend to think
of civil servants as having quite nice
lies and quite nice pensions and
relatively good work and paying
conditions but I think certainly for
ambulance drivers and Frontline workers
I think there is still that the sympathy
seems to be holding up so yeah the
government needs to kind of needs to
come to the table with some solutions I
think now I think that uh I think this
is not the 1980s you can't just do what
Thatcher did
um and just you know dig your heels and
it's just not going to work I'm just
just sticking on Rel just quickly Kevin
um the other thing that the rmt's cross
about is the fact that this is all
linked to productivity and changes in
working practices
um but actually that the transport
secretary determined on this uh you know
saying that some of them you don't have
to work on a Sunday you have to call
people in you have to get agreement from
staff to actually cover services on a
Sunday does the productivity changes
need to happen in the rail industry do
you think
um yeah possibly like the real industry
isn't the same now is it true it was
when the steam engine was invented it's
always changed and if there are areas
you you wish to get people working
differently you can negotiate that and
you can get agreement on that however if
you link them to the current dispute
you're going to prolong the dispute for
instance Mick Lynch has quite correctly
picked up on this idea of extending
driver only operations very limited now
most trains have a second safety
qualified person on the Train sometimes
they're checking fares but sometimes
they're operating the doors sometimes
they're doing both they're for security
Sarah's not alone you think there should
be a second person on the train I think
Mick Lynch has just realized that most
of the traveling public would agree with
them on that but if that was decoupled
from the pay negotiations I'm sure this
uh this real dispute could be settled
very quickly and then you move on to
negotiating about what happens with a
second person on on a train all the
disputes are slightly different some are
because workers are being certainly in
the NHS are really just dismayed up
what's happened to their public servers
some are because of changes management
want to make you look at Royal Mail some
are about pay I suppose that's a thread
through them all but they they're all
somewhat different I'm just amazed that
the government has beaten so so stubborn
and flat-footed on this like the
conservatives have managed to be
empowered for most of the past three
centuries because they've divided and
ruled now they clearly thought they
could just divide the trade unions and
Strikers from the public that's field so
I cannot Now understand why they don't
try and divide and rule by settling some
disputes and possibly spend a bit more
than they would have liked uh for
instance the the NHS but they're not
they're they're incompetent we know
we've seen that they're tiniered we know
that but I am I'm just mystified after
30 odd year because of covering
industrial disputes in one way or
another I just can't believe the
government's getting it so badly wrong
yeah but Kevin and I'll put this
question to Sarah actually
um even Ken Clark you know seen as a
sort of more liberal wing of the
conservative party suggested the
government has to stick to its guns on
this than actually increasing pay for
nurses and other sectors
um is unaffordable and it is
inflationary and it embeds high pay
rises in the system Sarah first Kevin I
know you want to come in Sarah I mean
that that is the government's main
argument isn't it on this
is their main argument and and it's it's
it's a logical argument but the thing is
I don't think that uh the public I think
I don't think people think about this
these particular strikes in a logical
way it's very emotional actually what's
going on because you're talking about
you know we've just been through covid
we've just seen uh our Frontline workers
you know we've got all those images of
nurses with you know masks making their
faces red and Tears in their eyes it's
it's been a very emotional two or three
years in that sector and I think people
just feel they deserve to be paid more
and yes the government is right of
course they can't afford it of course
the country can't afford it but um
people have decided people but you know
they've gotten into their heads that um
that we can afford anything because you
know furlough sort of put that seed into
people's minds well you know there's
always money to be found if we if we
need it and so this idea that okay it's
not it's not okay just to say we can't
afford it we have to afford it it's it's
emotional it's it's it's it's very
difficult for the government to maintain
this position because they just sound
like they're being really harsh and
really sort of you know a bit kind of
mandatory about it because it is just an
emotional issue and this is the problem
they have yes and even before furlough
the the bailout for the for the banking
sector you know back in the after the
financial crisis but but it is emotional
I'm just going to say that Pat Cullen
today saying there were 47 000 vacant
posts in this country alone and
presuming she met England at that point
every nurse coming on duty feels that
every patient feels that and even in the
Metro Kevin uh Rishi sunak talking about
how terrifying it is not knowing if an
ambulance is going to come so he's
bringing in the the emotional aspect of
this that people are feeling
yeah and Richie sunaka's prime minister
has presided over funding for the
ambulance service that means people uh
when there are no strikes I'm not sure
an ambulance is going to arrive or when
it will will be there so I think it's a
bit of a cheat just to focus on days
when they're on strike but there's no
there's no there's no doubt there is a
higher risk on those days but Ken Clark
you mentioned I remember the last
National ambulance dispute
1989-90 when there was strikes he was
held secretary he was very provocative
and he prolonged that strike by smearing
ambulance drivers as little more than
taxi drivers just ferry in old ladies uh
around often is what it is what he said
and he's no Oracle on the economy
because right if you work for a private
company and there's a pay rise and then
that company puts up the price to
whatever it sells in order to recoup
whatever it's paid you I understand how
that is inflationary but in the Health
Service how is it inflationary it's not
directly inflationally given somebody a
pay rise because we they it doesn't
charge us anything so you could give
nurses an ambulance Cruise pay rise and
it wouldn't be inflationary it depends
how you operate those companies now yes
I you might be going to jump ahead and
say there could be increased borrowing
that is absolutely right but the
government is increasing borrowing all
the time and during a period when the
economy is going into recession and
inflation isn't caused by weird rise as
it was caused by external factors not
least Putin's invasion of Ukraine and
what happened to world uh fuel prices
it's you can you can increase demand in
the in the economy you could protect
people's living standards I'm sorry I
just don't buy that all peer risers are
inflationary because they're not and Ken
Clark should know that well actually
given his recorders a chance sir see why
he doesn't yes and in fact looking at
the financial times as we head to
another story just one of the small
boxes on their front page suggesting
that ft analysis has Illustrated the
extent of real terms pay cuts for key
workers in recent years resulting first
austerity and big structural shocks
which we know about the pandemic and so
on across rail mail delivery and
education and it suggests that some big
fall to fit relatively High earners
lower paid public sector staff
especially in London face hardships so
more on that inside their paper in the
meantime their lead story is about
concerns about our critical
infrastructure this is after an attack
on Royal Mail and the guardian they say
and quite separately what happened in
America with the grounding of these
flights today
um Sarah raw mail warning of severe
disruption to its overseas services
okay
I know this stuff terrifies the living
daylight side of me I think we're much
too enthralled to all this technology
unfortunately we've become so completely
it rules our lives now we can't actually
function without it I mean you know you
can't do anything anymore without the
internet and the trouble is it's not a
safe place and people it is very
difficult to protect your um I mean I
think I think in the case of the
Guardian they've had
um people's salaries stolen and all
sorts of stuff all very personal details
and these these data these data uh I
suppose if you call them raids keep
happening and and we're we're powerless
really because we all are stuck using
the internet yeah and um the the Ft
saying that the national cyber security
Center which advises companies on
combating cyber crime is working with
the National Crime agency to understand
the impact another cyber security group
Kevin
um said that it could take months to
restore Royal Mail systems depending on
the severity of the incident so
suggesting the information cyber
attackers gained from having been on the
inside of an organization's digital
infrastructure can leave the victim
organization vulnerable to further
breaches and so it goes on yeah no
absolutely the guardian of Sarah says um
staff salary details and passports have
been uh compromised uh the work that the
journalists have been told to work from
home uh the Royal Mail don't send any
letters abroad because they their sister
their system is down I remember in the
NHS was hacked not long uh not that many
years ago and of course had very poor
operating system no I mean cyber
security is a huge issue individually
collectively now companies every
organization the government itself there
are people out there whether hostile
States or just hackers who think they
can create chaos
um perhaps a geopolitical ends and make
a lot of money but it's it's quite
frightening and sometimes I want to use
a little anxiety dreams I wonder what if
we wake up and you just find all your
Bank savings have just been wiped out
they don't keep ledgers anymore it
wouldn't be a piece of paper saying you
you had two grand or something in an
account it would just disappear yeah
don't put that in someone's mind Kevin
and please don't stress I'm sorry I've
done it now right it's the new year
I hate January
yeah this is all quite separate from the
airlines delayed or canceled In America
which is 10 000 flights were led to to
understand uh because of a government
pilot alerting system failure uh
prompting the Federal Aviation
Administration to Halt all departures
for 90 minutes quite an extraordinary
day certainly
um anyway lots more still to come
including the star promising it will
never mention Prince Harry again but we
will briefly in a couple of minutes back
a moment
foreign
[Music]
with me once again Kevin McGuire and
Sarah Vine from the mirror and the mail
respectively welcome back to both of you
um Sarah should we go to the Daily
Mirror which is continuing Revelations
about Boris Johnson and his apparent
complacency about partygate
well I mean this is one of the reasons
why all these um sort of hysterical toys
you keep wanting Boris Johnson to come
back just have to hold their fire
because we've really got to wait for
this inquiry to happen I mean I'm sure
I'm sure I mean the mirror is not
exactly Boris Johnson's greatest fan so
I would probably sorry
I didn't want to denigrate your front
page but I would probably take it with a
tiny bit of a pinch of salt
um but it's possible that uh more
Revelations will come out so we just
need to get this inquiry done and then
we can all have another conversation
about Boris Johnson
Kevin
there's an ITV podcast Series in which
they've interviewed people who worked in
Downing Street including one who says
that everybody were told to destroy
evidence began to destroying evidence
terrible atmosphere in the place
everyone's covering their backs
wondering who was the leaker of course
the mirror was pivotal brought the story
in the first place and the downfall of
the uh of the Prime Minister uh although
really brought himself down I think and
then stories at the the party on the eve
of the Duke of edinburgh's funeral was
more debauched than sugary's report uh
suggested now when as Sarah says
hysterical Tories say a Johnson will
come back he won't come back because all
these stories will come back and there
will be the inquiries under underway now
and did he know any mislead the uh the
House of Commons about these parties
when he was denying he went to any
parties or there were any parties or we
knew about any parties it could he's
more likely I think to be booted out of
parliament than he is to be prime
minister again Sarah do you think he
does want to come back sorry I don't
mean to interrupt you
want to yes I think 100 of course I
think he definitely does want to come
back and I think there are a lot of
people who do want him to come back but
what I think is that we need to wait for
this process to finish because until
we've had the proper inquiry and
everybody's had their chance to say
their piece and all the evidence that's
been presented we don't really have the
full picture and that's what we need and
it may be that he's exonerated and it
may be that he's not we simply don't
know
um as to whether he wants to come back I
think he definitely definitely does want
to come back
um I think he he feels very strongly
that um he was wrongly removed and um I
think he would like a chance to to you
know rehabilitate himself whether or not
he'll get that I don't know okay let's
move on to the Daily Star uh sling your
hook Sunbeam
a Daily Star bands man babies whinges
from best newspaper in the universe to
give readers a well-deserved break well
you're probably both
some of that the last bit of it the best
newspaper in the universe but anyway
um have you have you reached saturation
Point Kevin let's ask both of you
um I'm getting I'm getting close but
there is no doubt when uh incredibly
prominent Royal is tearing strips of his
family and I said I'm lighting that blue
touch paper here and she'll say it's
absolutely terrible what he's doing but
it's a it's it's a matter of public
interest we have this British
institution the monarchy which I'm no
great fan of
um but one who was inside is saying it's
absolutely rotten or all treacherous and
backstabbing and nasty and William also
got a bigger room in Balmoral when they
went upstairs but I think it's
absolutely fascinating I can't have
enough of it bring it on let's have more
videos to page war in the book Kevin
agent Maguire no I mean it's wow wow
from Harry I'm sorry you had a slightly
less good bedroom at Balmoral it's
Balmoral hello anyway but um I've
actually been I've been forced in a sort
of terrible torture to read most of the
book which is awful and um there are
many surprising things about this and I
think that it's all his perception for
start but also there are some really
curious things like he talks endlessly
about his penis the man is completely
obsessed with his penis and it's it's
very strange he's a odd combination of
it's really like a man-child as the star
says but then also sort of oddly sexist
and quite a lot of it he's a real man
best I think
um and I have to say Herman says that
I'm very mean about him I'm not actually
I feel quite sorry for him and I have
written that on a number of occasions
that he has had you know he had a very
difficult thing happened to him which
was awful and also on Camilla I
understand why he is a bit annoyed that
Camilla has you know married Sarah I'm
gonna have to cut you off and it's just
getting good as well I mean that was all
good but that bit anyway
um Sarah Vine Kevin McGuire thank you
both very much indeed